[Music]
[Applause]
hey guys welcome to the game of love i'm
your host lisa and this is dating
dodgeball today i'm accompanied by two
beautiful bachelorettes would you guys
like to introduce yourselves hi i'm
nicole i'm 21. i'm from redondo beach
and a fun fact is i love the happy face
fries from bj's um hi i'm jasmine i'm
18. i'm from tokyo japan
and i really like baking banana bread
but i don't have an oven so we're
pulling through
all right gentlemen the rules are simple
you guys are going to throw a ball at
the bachelorette you want to go on a
date with and there's only four slots
available on their teams so aim wisely
also ladies if you're feeling someone go
ahead step up and get hit but if you're
not
dodge those balls a my whistle begin
oh my god
oh what a shame
oh
oh wow oh my gosh they hit me
oh sorry
this is so much worse than i thought
[Music]
oh no it hit me
all right you can choose get hit by this
i dodge it
oh no
nicole's bench is now
full
okay
oh wow i got hit all right jasmine your
bench is now full unfortunately you
can't go on a date with everyone but you
can speed date them for 10 minutes and
then i'll be back and we have to
eliminate too
on my whistle
begin
what do you guys do i want to know a
little bit about what you do like what
you like to do um so i'm isaac i'm a
power lifter so i just squat bench and
deadlift as heavy as possible for like
one rep and i'm a huge foodie so i lift
to eat i don't eat to lift oh shoot hey
how you doing my name is makai
i do social media marketing and also
brand marketing for different movies so
probably your favorite movie who knows
how you doing my name is malik i love to
cook so if you can think of your
favorite dish
i got it okay we can cook together
together yeah i like cooking in the
kitchen a lot so hey i'm chase uh i'm an
actor i'm a tick tocker um i love doing
flips and so if you're interested in
that then maybe we could like flip and
do some stuff on the beach and stuff
that's sick i won't be flipping but i'll
cheer you on okay yeah
i'm a screen acting student right now um
i do a lot of like casting as well and
i'm interning at a talent management
company so i would love to see you guys
sing
one oh this one one
one line from any song okay can i have
like some snaps
go ahead you should let me love you let
me be the one to give you everything you
want any all right
[Music]
when i see your face
[Applause]
that is the end of this ten minutes
pretty intense do you know the two men
you're gonna eliminate oh my god you
guys are amazing
um
i'm gonna have to eliminate
you that's okay
i'm sorry we can't have two actors we're
not going to do it it's okay
i had a good time
congratulations guys you made it to
round three
welcome to round two gentlemen jasmine
this is your team
my whistle begin okay
hi besties what's up hello
uh can you guys tell me about yourselves
uh my name's seth uh right now i'm a
graduate student at ucla i'm from usc so
i don't know oh
well not to one up you but i am from
usda my name is maxwell i'm studying
computer science i read i do have an
oven and you're on campus you can come
buy baked banana bread how's it going my
name is ivan i'm 22
i don't go to school but i do work for
the government full time the government
yeah
my name is jether currently go to school
abroad actually i go to school in the
philippines
i love to rock climb i love to work out
i love to eat also you rock climb i love
climb
oh my gosh that's so so that could be
our first date
and like if you were like a disney
character like which one like would you
be i would be russell
because because when i was a kid i used
to be like i used to look like him you
know like that cute little circle face
oh i'm not gonna lie i don't say move on
represent okay represent i don't know if
you count this but like the new star
wars made by disney i would love to be
kylo ren oh okay yeah huge adam driver
fan but
look nothing like him
you know controversial answer but as a
kid i never watched a lot of disney
movies so i really can't say i have a
favorite or a favorite character i know
that's lame but you know what is what it
is what's your guys's bubble order okay
i'm sorry i'm gonna have a horrible
answer again
but i don't drink boba i don't know
anything do you guys have any like food
recommendations or like travel
destinations like you ever been a jolly
bee you want to go there
yeah um i've had jollibee i don't know
if it's different here but you haven't
had it with me
that is the end of the speed dating
round jasmine do you know who you're
going to eliminate
i know i can step out already
i'll just go ahead and do that real
quick
[Music]
you guys are so cool i hope you like
your stickers thank you thank you
all right congratulations guys this is
round three nicole picked three men from
her bench that her two finalists have to
hit in order for one-on-one time with
her but there's a catch if these men
catch the ball they are redeemed and
they get one-on-one time with her on my
whistle do not hit me
throw the balls
[Music]
um tell me a little bit about your past
relationships oh my past relationships
perfect one i've only been in one
serious relationship but i have enough
experience to say that
hello
tell me a little bit about your past
relationship um
so i've got my heart broken a couple
times but it's cool i'm just trying to
learn from each one yeah exactly i'm
just trying to figure out sorry a little
out of breath
[Music]
[Applause]
i think oh let me get back to you okay
do you know my name have we gotten your
meet name hello again great
um
past relationships i'll let you define
it to find that if we're going to talk
about things
yes but how many would you say that
you've been in
i think i would say like six five six
not a ton
um so i've never been in a relationship
oh wow yeah i've dated a bunch of people
but personally i'm very big on knowing
yourself before you kind of jump into
that i feel really good at the part of
my life that i am and i feel really good
with like independence yeah independent
know yourself before you go tell me a
little bit more about you like what are
your red flags or your turn-offs uh not
genuine red flags um i'd love to talk to
you in person if possible yeah but if
we're both not a good headspace prefer
that we uh
do your night i like the best breathing
as a surf instructor
and i just did a pranayama teacher
training cool is that like breath
related yeah it's a bunch of different
breaths
i mean it's just not ideal
that is the end of round three
all right on my whistle begin
[Music]
hey what's up
how are you i'm okay i like took an uber
for the second time in my life
surroundings do you always be sure to be
safe and like make sure everyone room
with like like you know oh yeah yeah
ellie is violent
how's it going hi
how are you
what was your last relationship with um
so my last relationship was
hey what's up again i'm here um i guess
i'll talk about me um i don't know i've
like had lost i've like had up like two
situations they're like really close
like my best friend i feel like you
should be careful
how much is like your like occupation
important to you what do you mean by
that i was like what do you want to do
in the future
definitely get my degree
physical therapy kinesiology is very
important
okay what are you going to do in this
youtube join the military and go law
enforcement so that's why i'm in the
reserves now you guys can study here and
study here
eventually i'm gonna have to go back to
the philippines for school because i'm
currently studying abroad
long distances has to be an option
eventually
what are you looking for in a
relationship um someone that could
actually
that has goals
like red flags red flags
asking for my phone
definitely if they're an astrology girl
um i guess like my red flags are like
when someone like
bad communication like they'll leave me
like on red or like oh my god when they
don't put lotion on their arms
oh we can't talk man
yeah that's the point
she's mine i'm just kidding i'm not
possessive anyway
that is the end of round three
congratulations guys for making it to
the final round nicole are you ready to
eliminate two people i think so are you
100 sure yeah because i'm giving you a
shared cash prize that you can use on
your first date with
this lucky gentleman
um this has been really fun you guys
thank you all so much for being here i
really appreciate it um
i'm going for this person because i
think that they have a really really
cool vibe
and so i'm going to be going with
bleak
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you guys so much
this is the final round congratulations
guys for making it this far
jasmine
do you know who you're going to
eliminate
hi besties
um you guys are so nice and super cool
and i really liked all the individual
little sparkles you had um i
will have to eliminate you
[Music]
[Applause]
okay wait i'm like 300.
okay where are we walking
[Music]
bye